[Applaudissements]
bonjour donc pourquoi devrait-on
s'intéresser aux jeux vidéos de nos
enfants pourquoi c'est important
malgré la jeunesse de jeux vidéo ça
l'est déjà surpassé les revenus de
l'industrie du cinéma et il ya déjà plus
de spectateurs qui regardent des parties
de jeux vidéo auxquels la plupart des
sports en fait leur part le super bowl
ya pas grand sport qui dépasse les
finales par exemple d league of legends
qui est un jeu vidéo c'est assez simple
tout le monde joue j'aimerais savoir les
gens à sale ceux qui jouent à des jeux
vidéo puis je compte à rebours sur votre
téléphone qui est quand même je sais
qu'après on dessus 60% lors de la salle
qui jouent à des jeux vidéo imaginez les
nouvelles générations
nous on est quand même un peu plus vieux
l'on n'est pas nécessairement avec les
jeux vidéo
les nouvelles générations sont nés avec
les jeux vidéo dès le début dans les
écoles primaires et ont tous des
téléphones intelligents ont tous un
petit jeu vidéo sur leur téléphone
sachant qu'on entend souvent parler des
problèmes dans le jeu vidéo
est-ce que ça les jeux vidéo apporte
comme problème je dis vraiment un côté
fun parce que souvent c'est beaucoup
d'unité c'est ce qu'on regarde en sommes
aujourd'hui
je crois fortement que si vous soucier
de ce que votre enfant fait derrière
l'écran et en jouant les jeux vidéo vous
pouvez l'aider à grandir et à s'épanouir
dans sa passion parlons de pourquoi il
est si important dans la prendre pour sa
part sur sa passion une passion ça
motive ça permet de s'épanouir dans un
domaine et de persévérer même quand
c'est super difficile ça ajoute à la vie
et c'est beaucoup plus facile
d'accomplir quelque chose si on en est
passionné si on s'en fou d'un sujet là
c'est vraiment difficile d'accomplir un
travail ou même que ce soit à l'école
mais que ce soit au travail si vraiment
le poids car souvent on laisse tomber où
on tourne les coins ronds ce qui est
vraiment très cool aussi avec la passe
on sait que t'as pas besoin d'avoir un
but pour eux
passionnément à quelque chose si vous
aimez lire connaît forme un but à lire
ou si vous aimez faire la musique ou
écouter de la musique il ya peu plus
parfois de but que d'écouter cette
musique là à l'adolescence
parfois il ya énormément de pression à
se trouver une carrière puis c'est là
que la passion peut vraiment faire une
différence dans la vie d'un jeune
bon tout d'abord démystifions un peul
estimant que l'on a envers les jeux
vidéo que les jeux vidéo c'est mal
et pour vraiment s'attarder à ce qui est
vraiment pourri peut être problématique
ils n'ont que 8 ça c'est dit m qu'elle
vous avez vu vous allez continuer à voir
pendant moi je vous dis aux gens qui
attaquèrent la génération qui garde
encore ses milieux nous quitte mais ils
vont rester un record a si longtemps
limites que les jeux vidéo rendent
violent que les jeux vidéo rendent anti
sociaux qui nous rend stupide et que
c'est pour les gars entre autres il y en
a d'autres mythes qui vous fait voir
pendant la tête que vous pensez dans la
tête
mais tous ces métaux l'or a été réfutée
par des gens qui sont beaucoup plus
intelligents que moi aujourd'hui je suis
pas là pour vous dire pourquoi c'est pas
des mythes
vous pouvez chercher vous même sur
internet mais je peux vous affirmer que
ça a été prouvé que c'est pas vrai
rappelez-vous dans le temps on trouve et
quel est heavy metal c'était dangereux
comment qu'aujourd'hui on peut penser à
ceux qui ont dû recommencer ridicule
pour moi c'est ça les jeux vidéo c'est
ridicule de penser que les juifs des
orages violents
par contre il ya quelques aspects des
jeux vidéos qui peuvent vraiment causé
problème à certaines personnes et
certains enfants peut-être vos enfants
commençons avec la cyberdépendance
moi je veux parler de cyberdépendance
parce qu'on utilise tout le temps pour
n'importe quoi c'est super important de
savoir que la sphère dépendance c'est un
phénomène qui est extrêmement rare c'est
un seulement un très faible pourcentage
de jeunes qui est cyberdépendants selon
jean vous lire une petite boucle selon
le site de ligne par un point comme on
parle de cyberdépendance lorsque le plus
d'un jeune pour un jeu l'empêchent de
fonctionner au quotidien ça ça veut dire
si votre jeune se lavent plus si votre
jeune ait eu de relations
interpersonnelles la vraie vie le qu'il
rend compte plus ses amis que vous avez
l'âme zara lui parler qui dit carrément
déconnecté du monde réel
oui peut-être que votre jeune soupe de
super dépendance mais toutes les autres
enfants qui peuvent jouer longtemps des
jeux vidéo on parle d'excès ou de
passion avec enthousiasme du jeu vidéo
et c'est aussi super important parce
qu'il faut pas le donner un diagnostic à
notre enfant de cyberdépendance
si même pas du tout là dedans si c'est
juste une passion pour lui qui cause ou
pas des problèmes à sa vie donc moi je
vais vous donner la métaphore du bo
accueilli parce que moi aujourd'hui je
veux parler d'excès de jeux vidéo et non
de cyberdépendance pour moi l'excès
c'est vraiment comme les brocolis dans
ce sens que si aujourd'hui en salles on
mangeait tous que du brocoli hockey
pendant un an on serait probablement
tous madame peut-être que tu peux tu
confirmer
oui on serait prêt à tous malades donc
si on n'a fait que jouer à des vidéos à
des jeux vidéo on va être tous mappy
raté mais ça dans votre tête
on est tous d'accord là dessus il en va
de même pour tout ce qu'on fait en excès
ok c'est pas juste les jeux vidéo j'ai
mis hou défi quelqu'un de de dire si on
peut déjà bien joie chez netflix donc un
côté netflix le pendant dix ans une fin
de semaine
est ce que ça vous a causé problème dans
votre vie à long terme
pas nécessairement c'était la même chose
pour les enfants qui jouaient le jeu
vidéo c'est pas parce qu'il joue un
week-end que c'est nécessairement nocifs
pourtant quand on parle de netflix on
est très très contents a parlé noémie et
avait vu la série hier je te mêmes
moyens de finir maniaque fait passer en
notes qu'il écoute on est tous contents
de lui que d'en parler alors que je l'
ai fini ennuis je vais pas dormir la
nuit pour l'écouter mais y'a pas
personne qui dit elle est déséquilibrée
et l'écouté netflix tout cas ni donc
c'est un peu comme ce qu'il faut
approcher les jeux vidéo ça arrive
parfois qu'on fasse un excès est ce que
c'est
format massif à long terme probablement
pas et c'est pour ça qu'il faut en
parler avec son enfant la cyber bâtiment
intimidations une super bonne nouvelle
avec la cyberintimidation ça c'est très
bizarre d'urss ensemble mais la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'on a arrêté de prendre
ça comme une blague et de dire ferme ton
écran fait cyber intimider par ce qui
est dit dans le fond c'est ça en ligne
ferme ton écran pis ton ordi forme ton
téléphone puis passe à autre chose
on est rendu qu'on prend ça au sérieux
et ça c'est super important parce que
c'est vraiment un problème de notre
société
la mauvaise nouvelle c'est justement on
peut pour fermer l'intrigué on est
connecté 24h sur 24 puis honnêtement je
crois pas qu'en pense société on est
outil à faire face à nos communications
qu'on fait en ligne il ya personne qui
nous a appris comment infligé l'internet
socialement il ya vraiment personne moi
personnellement je me souviens pas du
tout qu'on m'a dit tu peux pas dire
quelque chose par internet
ça se fait pas mais dans la vraie vie on
m'a déjà dit et tu peux pas envoyer
chier quelqu'un à l'école outil parce
que ça c'est pas bien mon mais jamais
dit comment utiliser l'internet qui je
suis convaincu que la plupart de vous
dans la salle sans vouloir déjà fait mal
à quelqu'un sur internet parce que vous
l'avez dit j'aime pas ton gilet parce
qu'il a été dit moi je déteste la
couleur rouge c'est aussi con qu'on est
pas capable de le dire un message et on
n'est pas capable non plus de le
recevoir tous nous touche tous nous
interpelle moi je pense qu'il est
essentiel que notre système d'éducation
intensifie ses efforts à cet égard ça
c'est super important parce que nous
enseignants doivent être soutenus dans
cette bataille
c'est une bataille qu'on a fait que
commencer puis qui va devenir
omniprésent dans la société
pendant ce temps leur parce qu'on sait
que le système d'éducation comme on a pu
le voir aujourd'hui ça peut être
compliqué a changé les parents peuvent
faire une différence nous ensemble on
peut faire une différence avec nos
enfants
je suis vraiment pas bien placé pour
vous dire comment vous devriez éduquer
votre enfant encore moins les disques et
sur l'internet
par contre une chose qui est sûre c'est
que votre enfant doit être conscient des
conséquences qui a de ses actes sur
internet qui peuvent parfois ceux
répertoriés dans la vraie vie
est ce c'est crucial parce que personne
qui nous dirigent et moi en tout cas il
ya personne qui m'a jamais appris ça on
commence à le comprendre notre société
mais les générations qui sont
présentement au primaire et au
secondaire qui ont leurs téléphones qui
ont peu accès à facebook à tous les
médias sociaux eux ne le savent pas
nécessairement et je voudrais vous dire
quand ils disent n'importe quoi sauver
médias sociaux qui est parce que moi
j'ai vu des adultes dire n'importe quoi
je garantis que des enfants qui n'ont
pas de conception de ce qu'est la
société disent aussi n'importe quoi et
c'est en s'intéressant vraiment à ce que
votre enfant fait que vous allez pouvoir
l'aider à grandir avec la technologie
par rapport à l'éducation et la
cyberdépendance et la subordination
je reviens aux jeux vidéo en apprenant à
connaître les habitudes de jeu vidéo et
la routine de votre enfant vous allez
pouvoir l'aider considérablement à
garder la clinique une vie équilibrée
pour nos ports qui tombe mal excité sans
l'empêcher de jouer à des jeux vidéo je
vous dis tout de suite si vous bénisse
et les jeux de votre famille
ça risque d'avoir l'effet contraire que
vous voulez à voir avec votre enfant
il est bien plus efficace doit tenter de
le motiver 8 même à balancer sa vie que
de retirer une de ses passions préféré
garder l'objectif en tête
est ce que vous voulez que votre enfance
s'épanouissent dans sa vie et qu'il soit
heureux qu'il soit équilibré dans ses
activités
qu'il n'oublie pas ses amis sa famille
ses études
l'activité physique mais qu'ils puissent
aussi y avoir une passion qu'il fait
vibrer que ce soit le jeu vidéo la
musique les hors la réponse est oui
alors d'après moi la réponse est oui
vu un jeu c'est pas 2 mais pour moi la
réponse serait oui comment on fait ça
parce qu'il ya peut-être des gens ici
l'égide de l'osce à les interpelle peau
qui comprennent pas pourquoi leurs
enfants jouer à des jeux vidéo pique ça
les intéresse tout simplement pas
comment on parle de jeux vidéo avec
notre enfance si nous ça nous intéresse
pas ben c'est aussi simple que pour
celui des questions en posant des
questions avec votre enfant à votre
enfant
par rapport au jeu vidéo ça va vraiment
tout changer la dynamique au lieu de se
renfermer est petit et il va prend
vraiment vouloir vous en parlez vous
allez devenir de moins en moins
néophytes de la station vous allez
vouloir vous même vous intéresser chaque
joueur est différent et on joue tous
pour des différentes raisons peut-être
que votre jeune joue juste parce que
c'est le fun mais peut-être aussi qu'il
joue parce qu'il veut s'échapper de sa
réalité à l'école
peut-être qu'il se fait intimider
peut-être que il s'est fait des amis sur
internet peut-être qu'il y est tombé en
amour serait temps qu'ils jouent avec
cette personne là vous le savez
peut-être pas ce qui se passe lors
salies qui sait en âprement je crois en
parlant de jeux vidéo ça peut ouvrir
cette porte
cette porte que peut-être votre jeune
renferme depuis toujours parce qu'il
pense que ça vous intéresse pas est ce
qu'ils aiment les jeux d'aventuré de
stratégie peut-être que je parle chinois
pour vous mais votre jeune il va savoir
exactement de quoi il parle
demandez-lui quel type de jeu il m
est-ce qu'ils jouent à des jeux
multijoueurs
est-ce qu'il joue solo est ce qu une
partie peut être interrompue soit ça
peut être super important ça peut
changer votre dynamique est ce qu'il ya
des amis avec qui il joue est ce que ses
amis le cd a mis en ligne qui habite un
peu partout en allemand ou si des gens
locaux qu'on vous pouvez rencontrer
ensemble
soyez intéressé à une vidéo de votre
j'aime et je vous dis que ça va changer
vos relations avec lui surtout s'il joue
énormément
la bonne nouvelle dans tout ça c'est
qu'il ya un tas davantage que votre
enfant j'aurais des jeux vidéo s'y loger
parlait beaucoup de négatif
mais je veux finir sur notre pouce si je
dis oui aux jeux vidéo parce que c'est
simple non seulement c'est amusant ça
les met à l'aise avec la
technologie un très jeune âge mais le
jeu va lire la liste parce qu'elle est
incroyable la liste de bénéfice de jouir
des jeux vidéo ça améliore la
coordination la résolution de problèmes
l'attention la concentration la vitesse
du cerveau le multi tasking la
coordination mais il la motricité fine
samian la mémoire développent les
compétences et lecture en mathématiques
en technologie puis le sas rôle dans je
les vois plus il y en a tellement là que
vous seriez surpris si votre jeu jeunes
jouaient déjà en équipe ça a de la
collaboration la coordination la
corporation ça peut l'aider avec ces
interactions sociales
ça peut lui monter son estime de soi
parce que devient bon à un jeu alors
peut-être qu'il n'était pas doué en
sport ou dans d'autres choses
il ya tellement de points positifs aux
jeux vidéo que c'est un fait beaucoup
plus du silence ernéen qu'elle inverse
puis c'est vraiment partout aujourd'hui
il ya tellement d'emplois dans le jeu
vidéo ça peut ça devrait pas du tout
vous inquiéter c'est plus comme avant le
jeu vidéo là c'est une machine ah oui
argent mais à emploi pas juste des
emplois par passion payer le maintenant
on fait des jeux vidéo vraiment des
villes entières là dessus par exemple
montréal c'est un des piliers un
développement de jeux vidéo
puis ça a même une superbe un mix
ampleur la technologie qui est vraiment
incroyable
à montréal on est les temps partout dans
le monde qui ont travaillé ici donc que
ce soit pour travailler derrière le jeu
vidéo à faire les jeux vidéo ou à
travailler devant et devant je veux dire
à jouer près ferment à devenir
journaliste à devenir
il ya des gens qui travaillent à la télé
l'écriture à n'importe quel autre job
que je vais penser qu'ils rallient aux
sports on l'a aussi langer vidéo des
managers et des directeurs des
publicistes moi j'ai tout ça en tant que
joueur professionnel pour vrai l
instruction est vraiment en train de
changer toute la société
je vous mets un défi
si vous vous intéressez pas du tout aux
jeux vidéo ce soir si vous avez
quelqu'un de notre famille qui priment
jeu ou qui joue je me défie ce soir de
lui poser une question sur le jeu peu
importe la question si vous posez une
question de genre pourquoi tu aimes
jouer quel genre de jeu un petit jouet
c'est quoi tes jeux préférés je vous
demande pas de jouer je demande juste de
vous ouvrir l'esprit au fait que le jeu
vidéo les jeux vidéo sont là pour rester
fac au lieu de devenir de rester ritz à
la situation de vous ouvrir à je
voudrais cette nouvelle ère de médias
que l'on a qui vient rejoindre le cinéma
les livres la littérature extra puis ça
c'est moi qui je veux vous dire que mes
parents c'est vraiment la raison qui
fait que je sois encore en jeu vidéo
la façon qu'ils ont abordé ma carrière
avec empathie et compréhension ça fait
longtemps qu'il aurait fallu que je
quitte les jeux si jamais il n'avait pas
supporté
aujourd'hui comme on ne m'en souvenais
plus tôt cinq coupes du monde peter
forster dit à noter aussi en 2014 100
femmes la bbc en 2016 personnel à vélo
québec en 2010 ils jouissent de jeux
vidéo à temps plein je suis sur la scène
d'un ted x pour vous explique comment
les jeux ont façonné ma vie à cause de
mes parents
[Applaudissements]